يعرض برنامج الجزيره التحقيقي ما خفي اعظم
مساء اليوم الجمعه تحقيقا جديدا من تونس
يكشف تفاصيلا مثيره تتعلق باحداث امنيه
كبيره عصفت بالبلاد خلال السنوات الاخيره
ولا تزال طي الكتمان ما خفي اعظم حصل في
تحقيقه الجديد الذي يحمل العنوان تونس
الايادي الخفيه على تسريبات ووثائق حصريه
تميت اللثام عن شخصيات نافذه متورطه في
هذه الاحداث ولم تحاسب حتى اليوم التحقيق
الذي يقدمه زميل تامر هل التقى شخصيات
مرتبطه بتلك الاحداث في ظل التحديات
الامنيه والسياسيه التي تشهدها تونس هذه
الايام تذكر ان المشهد التونسيه يعيش
حاليا استقطابا حادا على وقع اتهامات
للرئيس قيس سعيد لتصفيه حسابات سياسيه عبر
القضاء مع معارضيه وفتح ملفات ضدهم في
الوقت الذي يصمت فيه عن ملفات اخرى لا
تزال تثير كثيرا من الجردل وعلامات
الاستفهام برنامج ما خفي اعظم تونس
الايادي الخفيه ياتيكم اليوم عند العاشره
وخمس دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه على شاشه
الجزيره ومنصاتها المختلفه